so it's frozen senses to me and this is
great so you remember the
the show lamb chop when you were a kid
it was that kid's show lamb chop
i'm sure you remember it um
well after
lamb chop ended
after lamb chop ella ended uh molly
lewis was her name
she decided she still wanted to have a
career
she still wanted to have a career and
she decided
well now that i'm under contract i think
it's 2008.
i am gonna take my show on the road and
i
am gonna make it spicy
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls and
all our magical friends in the audience
please welcome the third generation of
performers sherry lewis's daughters
mallory lewis and lam chop oh this is
sorry i apologize it's sherry lewis's
dollar daughter
apologize this is her daughter
all right look we got it we got a new
lamp chop cool all right
taking up taking after her mom
gonna do a fun new kids show
hey liam job why are you wearing a burka
because i'm hiding you're
hiding who are you hiding from i'm
hiding from al qaeda
okay it was pretty topical 2008 right i
guess
oh my why are you hiding from al qaeda
well you know how mean they are to the
women you should
see what they do to their sheep
they have sex with her sheep is what
she's referring to
[Music]
[Applause]
you think her mom thought that this is
where she wanted her character to go
her famed kids show to be this that's it
young lady
no more msnbc for you
oh that is so unfair because i love the
news especially
politics in fact i'm claiming show
business
and i'm gonna run the president of the
united states
all right here we go [ __ ] lamb chop
2020 guys
[Applause]
well why not everybody else is anyhow
i think if you ran for president it
would be a real case of shocking
oh no no no seriously
this could be my year they have a black
man running they
have a woman running why not a lambo
you're white it's not that you're a lamb
that's the problem
i just don't think the american public
is ready to have a puppet for president
here comes a joke
get it ah you see the look you see that
look like ah
see that look as politicians are puppets
look at that look at that look
because politicians are puppets man
actually we got a house full of dems
tonight
why don't we do a little experiment and
let me blindfold you
oh no sister says the kinky stuff for
later
let's let's see how good your mind
reading skills are
all right i am looking at a man
someone else is new ah because she's a
[ __ ]
laptops calling out for being a [ __ ]
what can you tell me about what that man
is thinking
[Laughter]
hey it's coming oh
sure
oh such naughty thoughts
honestly you really are acting like you
think you're hot stuff tonight
oh i don't
oh why are you making lamb chop so sad
i know i'm not stuck
i'm tonight hot southern california
harrison comes to me though
tower baby
this is the bit that doesn't end
[Music]
i can be greater sooner or later i'm
greater than you now you're not
yes i am she's not yes i am
yes i am
[Music]
i can hold longer
yes i can
[Applause]
vegas act that she's doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no you can't can't can't
yes i can
i guess her mom i guess her mom must
have left the
you know the rights and everything to
her right
the comments are turned off oh no she's
done a lot of these
she does because i am the star
[Music]
you know she only got this job because
he was in the family
you know it's funny that the [ __ ]
lamb is actually telling the truth
i got this job because i had the hand
that fits what
ever come on lamp
can't you even admit that i hold up my
end
admit she holds up my hand because it's
her hands up her butt
and let me tell you that hurts
lamb chop you used to be such a nice
cute sweet kind funny little puppet
yeah i have a fiber stuff today i do
why don't you just call me
oh nice cute sweet kind funny little
puppet
[Laughter]
what is so funny but it's so funny
malories i'm not
your pocket you are my thought
so sweetie lamb chop i'm a ventriloquist
i don't care that she is a vanilla twist
so vanilla
she didn't say that she's saying the
words wrong on purpose to be funny
now what that means is i make you talk
without moving my lips
much anyway
it is no big deal making someone talk
without
moving your legs look i'm making myself
talk about moving my lips right now
[Music]
all right sweetheart enough and now
ladies and gentlemen
what are you doing uh
there's another act and i was trying to
say goodbye
yeah do your closing bid are you gonna
do this song that doesn't end
you guys don't want me to go do you
no well that's [ __ ] up for the act
coming up afterwards why would you do
that
i don't think they're all that fond of
you
i'm sorry honey but when i say we gotta
go
we gotta go what do you say to that
you are such a big shot
she's gonna call her a [ __ ] but she
didn't he's in charge a little cotton me
oh
[Music]
here i am just trying to have some fun
earn enough living
and bring some cheer into room tots
healthy drinkers
[Applause]
yeah people did pay to watch her act
here comes the song
[Music]
please don't be offended but it has been
wrecked amended
that as soon as this song's ended no
it's not can laughter it's at some sort
of vegas club
you should say goodbye
let's just make this song the fast one
cause it's gonna be
your
[Music]
it'd be hilarious if just like the same
thing the guy who played big berg
big bird his son just goes on the rack
with like an r rated big bird uh
stand-up special
[Music]
please
[Music]
i guess this kid does one and it's just
like very hard our
racial humor
[Music]
disney immediately suits her
[Music]
if you guys enjoy like branson missouri
this does feel like a branson missouri
[ __ ]
act it really does
oh she's doing it
i was kidding
[Music]
it's her song
you think she's mad that they didn't
give her the tv show
when her mom finished you think that
she's upset that they didn't get the tv
show
oh god there's a there's a picture of
malory lamb chop with joe biden
and [ __ ] kamala harris of course
of course there is
[Music]
killed it [ __ ] killed him
uh those are the video yeah yeah there
is there is actually pic that was just
sent to me of
mallor mally lewis
i said shelly that was mally lewis with
uh
biden and with kamala harris so
i guess she's still doing it she's still
touring
let's see let's see where she's at well
probably no one's touring now because of
the
mallory lewis and lamb chop
website
sherry lewis and lamb chop a legacy
starring malay lewis lamb chop
oh look they sell lamb chop mask
bookings you could book her media
inquiries look at that
that's pretty cool right guys
uh it's not an only fans it's not an
only fans